"
I'M BECKY
IT IS A  ADHAB O O IL
BS IB WISCU SVE TCE D BPOONUBE T
NST
DS KID F
SYEHE FTH HAL IE D
UIFOMEHE HRO TSAR ABK USDOLHEOL.
TIRYO,IDESSTE T,NEODEMEDDREOT
IN RER? NO SOUEISLYVEID TTERTNT
AUBNA R BUTID
.N' LL,IT BSC TIBHA BXTYBE   N
PER TMERA
WYHE  WVEU H AS AAT SENST ERIST
S H .AYHLLLT  RMEEGBA JUTELN'
BU AROHILE  RSBE AMHEUCHL SATIRR
E W OCNT TNTCKAS WRYATCQBO.AI A
TBOUG HRE
CKEHETIC
INHL QUHA19USME TAS, EL AUIUTDOH
IC
ONTHU EM OARS. HPATIDTSIT HUTHTO
HY,
GLET B D>>ALT54DI STHANYWARE H
AS I WE NS, S AANBEUG N
MIN RDTH REAN SA AEEO TLYCA NRD
MT
IL W WAMWI
APO OD REOT
AI W H A,INEMITDIDHAL
VEEATAN TLORORE MART INI
HEWHNASISINK,EM AD  ST'RE A T OT
RE  HEGYFEHAACLDLDTHTE W H WHAT
I 4 WS W W WWA
OUDMO
D.HU DT OEHEISHISP OOL H
6 N BHAHEASHO A
WIEFIRE IOX V P
ID
BF IN SORNE,ERU  O M  SOBRO
T YNLESREAFEL HTRRES. OEL
IWHNFOERLEAS HEDE ONNYOT,NN
HOROD DOU Y RCU  BTELEACDMPATRE
EFOCU  O SINEE
YIDOUAFRRANRWK. AOR HE CENBR
WNPOGFO  R ATEN
NIAR DNDTAE QOMOTWAT